désolé je suis comme si nous n'avions jamais pensé que tu
partais ça va me manquer je prends juste quatre ans de
chillin j'ai eu un travail aujourd'hui en
écrivant pour le Jackson Journal super
tu peux écrire ma nécrologie Charlotte
Phelan papa sa fille toujours célibataire je
pense quand tu  fini de frapper l'eau
merci comme un cheval gagnant au Kentucky
Derby J'ai rédigé l'
initiative d'assainissement de la santé à domicile pour ce que je facture
qui exige que chaque maison blanche ait une
salle de bain séparée pour la santé Je ne
devrais que vous construire une salle de bain à l'extérieur de
Haley ces  les femmes élèvent des enfants blancs
nous les aimons et elles nous aiment mais elles
ne peuvent même pas utiliser les toilettes dans nos maisons
vous êtes nombreux là-dedans vous avez dit que vous aviez
raison sur ce qui me dérange
surtout si cela ne dérange personne d'autre
j'aimerais  lis quelque chose du
point de vue de l'aide que je veux
t'interviewer
aucune femme de chambre ne te dira jamais la vérité
c'est un sacré risque à prendre dans
le courage de Jackson Mississippi en
étant juste courageux de surmonter la peur
et d'oser faire w  chapeau est vrai votre
prochain pousse votre esprit mon dieu Hilly Holbrook me manque
Je suis tous de l'aide avec vos histoires nous
aimons tous vous m'avez tous amené là-dedans mais je
vais le finir
avez-vous perdu la tête aucun homme mais vous
revenez à  ça pointe des bougies
ça ressemble à Jackson si tu me demandes
tu dis une croyance est-ce que j'ai des projets pour
elle tu es impie